[Music]
now to Nicaragua where these Daredevils
are about to bore down the side of an
active volcano I know about samboni
[Laughter]
sandboarding down an active volcano on
sharp rocks what could possibly go wrong
you got to be careful because if the
volcano erupts you could fall on your
ash so why have they chosen to bore down
the side of this volcano these
Daredevils speeds approaching 60 miles
per hour or a hundred kilometers per
hour they've got this feed because
they've picked the right volcano Serra
Negra is a cinder cone also known as a
scoria cone which is a small yet
explosive volcano a cinder cone like
this is formed from eruptions the magma
erupts into the air where it solidifies
and forms these scoria rocks and then it
falls down right around the eruption
site and so it builds up a very steep
cold of rock the slope of the volcano is
30 degrees it's that steep slope that
allows gravity to really act on these
riders and get them up to these insane
speeds the key to this volcano having
such steep sides is the fact that it's
incredibly young this volcano last
erupted in 1999 and in geological terms
that's pretty much yesterday sledding so
pass down the side of an active volcano
looks like a lot of fun and it's very
impressive
however the dismount looks incredibly
painful Wow whoa that must really hurt